[Music]  thank you this one's not bad  it smells kind of like your the beach  with a cocktail like a blended cocktail  this one I give a 3.5 oh God  grandma soap gross like grandma house it  burns your nose hairs like sharp notes  negative one this place smells my  masculine strange is turning blue fresh  like breezy clean almost like this see  kind of it makes me think of a naked man  so I would say four out of five it's a  big one this smells like fruit melons  berries like girly girly girl it like  teenage girl it definitely has that like  kind of [ __ ] scent at 2.5  I know this one  I feel like boys in high school used to  wear this mus and like bedivere maybe  musk is typically derived from testicles  of a specific animal this would last  sudden someone's body like 72 hours I  think I would give it a 4 out of 5 I  can't but breeze this is the [ __ ] one